[Music]
comedian Katt Williams has been in the
news lately a lot of bizarre behavior
crazy from Katt Williams there's cat and
a very talented guys very funny but he's
been he's been getting to some wacky
trouble lately first Katt Williams
pulled a gun on another comedian at a
comedy club oK we've all done that then
cat had a meltdown on stage in Oakland
and tried to fight several people in his
audience okay then he was chased by
police while riding a three wheel
motorcycle well this past weekend I'm
not making this up it's been all over
the news Katt Williams was in a Target
store and a surveillance camera caught
him slapping one of the employees and
then driving off on a scooter cart
there's footage of the incident let's
take a look
and there's the employee there's cat and
he hits him slaps him and then I guess
he's trying to call somebody and cat
makes a very slow getaway and I think
what is he taking something here I don't
know
grab me some napkins for his run away
yeah very slow two mile an hour run away
on a scooter card anyway here to comment
on this Katt Williams story is one of
our writers he's got something to say
mr. Deon Cole
thanks Conan America there is nothing
wrong with Katt Williams believe me he's
fine see what African American comics go
crazy that's the sign that we made it
all greats that I love annamaya have
went crazy at one point Richard Pryor
Eddie Murphy Dave Chappelle Martin
Lawrence Tracy Morgan and as Katt
Williams turn see I admit this that it
has inspired me and I feel as though in
order for me to become the next great
african-american
so that's what I did lobster anything
I've gotta blow off the note our ID on
coal everybody
[Applause]